senior Administration officials tell CBS
News The Man Behind a notorious attack
at Afghanistan's main airport has been
killed by the Taliban 13 Americans and
many Afghans died in that explosion
during the final U.S withdrawal in 2021.
David Martin has more
the deadly blast at Abby gate
was set off by a lone suicide bomber
sent by ISIS into the chaos outside the
airport in Kabul the uh individual
from the Isis cell that planned The
Abbey gate bombing was killed by the
Taliban Darren Hoover father of Staff
Sergeant Taylor Hoover who died from the
blast found out in a phone call from the
Marine Corps does it matter to you
uh whether or not it was the Taliban
that apparently killed him or the United
States I don't care it's one less
terrorist that we have to worry about
does it feel like justice
to you to me it won't be Justice ever
it happened early this month in fighting
between the Taliban and Isis the Taliban
apparently did not realize who they had
killed but the U.S found out they've got
it from several different sources that
this individual was indeed killed 45
other servicemen and women were wounded
in at least 170 Afghan civilians killed
in the 2021 attack I opened my eyes to
Marines dead or unconscious lying around
me former Marine Tyler Vargas Andrews
was riddled by more than 100 ball
bearings and remains bitter no
government officials have been held to
account for the chaotic withdrawal the
11 Marines one sailor
and one soldier that were murdered that
day have not been answered for for CBS
mornings David Martin at the Pentagon